[Music]
it was a freestyle version it was a free
cover you'll notice the audio setup is a
bit different
well yeah we have long story short we
have better audio now but it's gonna be
a bit clunky for a while as you can see
the board is sitting here on the table
and we're still kind of drowning in
equipment here your equipment and you
guys could be drowning in wine right now
when you start up with wink oh my god
wink delivers wine right to your front
door they pick out the best tasting wine
that's perfect just for your palate okay
and there right now they're giving you
$20 off your first order when you go to
try wink that's t ry winc comm slash
annejulien they'll even cover shipping
check them out really really really
really awesome peeps and an awesome
service also guys join lift the
ride-sharing company that believes it's
treating their people better they do
everything they can to make sure drivers
are happy on every trip and right now
they're looking for drivers they're
looking for you guys they're looking for
you they're looking for you right now ly
ft it's nice right ly ft.com /m Julian
you get yourself a new $500 new driver
bonus limited time only check them out
okay we will get back to the sponsors
first of all I'm on the other side today
hopefully it didn't give too many of you
guys like a shock but he wants to use
the ball I don't want to use it I'm
trying to make sure this whole thing
works cuz we're recording on the
computer and recording video on the
camera which is a new thing for us it's
actually a new thing but it's how we
started the podcast you remember that
yeah we used to have the laptop here
recording our shitty USB mics and now we
have the audio quality should sound a
lot better now like we
came full circle we have came full
circle we have him I want to leave we
have to know yeah okay we're gonna turn
the headlights for dinner
Wow wait like oh yeah I like this thing
okay you'll have that you'll have the
voice and I want okay so nothing so
funny we're in a weird mood today yeah
laughs Circle tell me tell me what you
like to eat a lot of just say I like to
eat a lot of and then give me a cool I
also like using cool what else you got
[Laughter]
this is just pitch change pitch change
you like to karaoke or like the game
yogi one is dogs [ __ ] my name is Dora I
have a basketball game tomorrow okay
does it record this like inner voices it
is this whole podcaster it's gonna be us
laughing and nothing I'm almost positive
it's recording in exactly how they
sounds because I was getting nauseous
and I was gonna throw up on top of my
microphone like on you nasty I have
Jesus in my pocket pocket cheese
speaking of pocket cheese's this episode
of general impact is brought to you by
pocket Jesus never go anywhere without
Jesus in your pocket no okay so
so what actually I had to introduce it
in that what had a segue into the
introduction someone suggested in the
comments that we have like a segue off
so I was thinking of like how we can do
that because Julien is far more
experienced in the segwaying than I will
ever be and he does the the sponsors
every week and his fire segues are
nothing short of legendary thank you I
figured we put some oh there's like one
or two real things in there but we put
some fake products or sponsors into a
sorry about that
what the [ __ ]
that's just your computer telling ya it
might not have recorded out on our we'll
see we put some fake and real sponsors
in the Cup and the goal the game is
we're gonna have a conversation Jenna
has four I have form we have to
seamlessly weave all of our sponsors
into the conversation but we do have two
real sponsors lift lifting wink by the
way guys are the sort of sponsors of
this podcast episode other ones are fake
it's not real so every time we tell you
to go buy something or dirt you know
whatever comm such a visually it's fake
unless it's wink or lift okay this is a
fake podcast what is she doing she's
laying on the table what is she what is
she though she looks like a giraffe she
is she's my giraffe yeah she's not deaf
okay are you ready to draw you I love I
graduated from moving your own mic to
moving my mic I know I know I'm such a
control for I'm sorry babe that's
annoying I'm really sorry okay
go ahead why don't you pick out your
first big sponsor I'm gonna get my ass
handed to me in this okay do I look at
it now yeah captain don't I tell I'd say
I think so yeah so then we can know this
one is melatonin protein shakes by
bodybuilding.com see you have a nice
relaxing pose
all right I got it
oh my god Tampax it streams for it oh my
god okay you got a trap in I got Gerrans
came in Jackie if you were here last
episode jared is the pork a man rest in
peace
we got eat on the show the wheel we
named we named him Jared it's just some
guy killed the little baby came in and
we decided his name was Jerry Jerry
Jerry this name is spelled
jay-ar yeah damn it
I got coca-cola boy but that could be
that can also be really good classic all
right
ooh rat poison getting all the good ones
damn it let me open my gun damn it can
we trade audio technica speakers for it
yeah I think yes Audio Technica speaker
sporks it's a speaker built in your
spoon I'm gonna lay my not right here
but you can't look at them okay
I got Elmer talking for flops and my
last one is all natural limb skin
condoms nice that's a real thing all
right
do it here's our like better than mine
and you're better it said guys like I'm
set up to fail damn it alright when
they're counting you out and you're set
to fail that's when you got to dig deep
dig real deep
alright you come out of winter you dig
deep sky high everyone's banking on you
to lose because you think they think
you're a loser but you're not a loser
you need to believe in yourself every
meal counts which means every meal no
trying to lift your spirits if you'd
gone somewhere with that like we I
really we have to judge each other yes
yes the other person has to approve the
the segue oh oh yeah oh is this fazer
this is phase no it's no like this my
name is Troy I have a basketball game
tomorrow I'm a point guard so we were
talking when Brent was here last weekend
we literally sat down we like had no
alcohol nothing we were just hanging out
and we decided to watch some of
Nightmare fuel yeah Julian's album all
right this is not say anything yeah we
we turn on nightmare fuel yeah which is
conveniently packaged into one video on
my youtube channel so but so we we like
well cuz I saw on Twitter someone
tweeted at me nightmare fuel all at once
and they took all of your songs and laid
them on top of each other and made one
just awful sound which I don't know how
I can ever think that person or not for
doing those yeah but I mean speaking of
flame things I've talked to each other
you get yourself some Elmer's hot glue
flip-flops because it's hot glue layered
on top of itself and then you get flip
flops oh my god I know how you feel now
I don't know how to feel I feel like
I've been taken for a ride
you're like the conversation we just had
that mean anything to you are we just
now you know how it feels is brutal
that's brutal
all right I don't know how to feel
honestly got those did I do it you did
it that was an incredible city by the
way the reason why I even wrote this
down as a thing was because I saw a hack
video online hot-glue hacks it was on
[ __ ] Facebook which I'm never on I
really was angry about the words please
but it was like hot-glue hacks and some
of them were just the most garbage trash
[ __ ] I've ever seen one of which was he
literally took a piece of cardboard and
just hot glue all over it and then let
it dry and then decided that they were
shoes I was like boy if you don't
anyways we sat down and we watched a lot
of Nightmare fuel cuz I was trying to
find no more fuel all at once yeah and
um that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny
yeah it's not funny if you hear it all
the time but it's funny people back and
listen to it it's also funny in the
least like cerebral way ever it's just
like you're so weird enough and that
it's that kind of funny um I'm gonna
lower your levels limit if you want to
play like a little bit closer you just
grow on trees but what's in my hat
listen to all the songs in it like
they're jumping everywhere why usually
was hanging why didn't you do it
nightmare and I'm her fuel volume too
and I didn't have an answer for that why
haven't you made another one I need to
make it sound like it's a particularly
long process to make them you made that
like a weekend you know what the
physical manifestation of Nightmare fuel
happen in a weekend but what's not being
a real video it's coming I'm just trying
to talk that up to that being a real
thing takes months an artist process
cannot be rushed months like 2015 or
something months at least 24 ounces what
would make you think that I'm looking at
my sponsors I know I honestly did I
thought about no Muirfield for a long
time and before it actually that
we went to Vegas whatever it's going in
Las Vegas there's a farce for the
mirrors that's not a forest it's the
path of what you take to get to place
two there we're in Las Vegas am I in the
hotel room okay feeding our wonderful
hotel room service and I was trying to
eat more and faster but all I had four
Forks and Mary during my meal and I also
kind of listened back to the nightmare
fuel from the sport because audio
technica now makes speakers Forks okay
you gotta Audio Technica calm / doing
get your speaker sports and that that
way you can reverie sort of food they
now come in chopsticks forks speak girl
- so you can eat every sort of food and
they have a Bluetooth speaker playing in
the background
oh my god that was really good I mean I
saw it coming a little bit but that was
I mean thank you I mean you're good at
what you do what can I say I you know
I'm a man a few times and when I'm good
at those things I'm gonna be good at it
I'm I'm really really good at falling
asleep with the light on sometimes like
I pretty much don't even turn off the
lights ever I sleep with them like
completely on I'm also really good at
hitting my shin on the bed when I go to
the bathroom the morning that's - I do
that do that well you just say also
really good hydrating I want to take
them away from you I'm gonna take your
daughter she's so shy about Communitech
I'm good at dogging I have a good dog
she's a good why are you so floppy why
she's such a you just said that you're
really good at falling asleep the lights
on which reminded me that michael.lowe
priori said
earlier that Domino's was pizza for
vampires that's so funny because nobody
really liked orders at least like in a
city no one really orders Domino's like
by choice it's always because they're
open super late and it's like you're
that hungry I need something to eat well
if you think about it like we've I've
got you know before first of all before
I went vegan right I had a couple stouts
with Domino's which I failed miserably
and I hate Domino's for it never need
diamonds again but you know I tried a
couple that they introduced the
gluten-free pizza it turns out it wasn't
really gluten free and it got me sick
pretty bad a couple hours but there were
a couple times where I had Domino's
Pizza and I'm thinking of a couple
different my entire life by choice
drinks caffeine free my father does that
too right yes that's gnarly
drinking decaf coffee in caffeine free
coke there's no point
it's a while there's no point that's why
you might as well use it to poison rats
which is if you have rats guys get rat
poison because rat poison calm sausage
annejulien is giving you
hundred pounds of rat poison yeah you go
to rat poison comp sauce Jen and Julian
the moment you go to that URL the rat
poison will be arriving at your house at
that time and they'll I don't know I
think that's like but it was too close
to my side I really wanted rat poison
cuz I wanted to start talking about
something that you should drag that rat
and then after that you should poison
that rat trap in the back do I have to
redo that one no I just lost it yes how
was mine yours was great except for the
thing that you cried through the whole
thing it's a rat poison I lost by those
two dad it was okay okay not your fight
not you find this week I lost it it's
fine don't leave that I'm like wow it's
totally fine okay
what's fine I don't really want to be
here anymore and I don't feel like
driving so I'm just gonna hop up and
grab a lift and you know what's funny
you guys joined lift you could be
picking me up I mean that's not what
they told me to market it but just but
lift is looking for new drivers right
now guys and if you sign up right now
are we halfway do I get a $500 new
driver bonus new driver bonus okay
lyft is a ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
guys happy drivers and happy passengers
no surprise 9 i-10 lift rides get a
perfect 5 star rating
okay I take lips all the time love my
experiences everyone's always so nice ok
so if you're ready to earn hundreds of
dollars per week plus tips around for
lift with express way you get paid
almost in Suzy instantly and lyft is the
first ride sharing platform to integrate
tips right into the app you keep a
hundred percent of the tips and lyft
drivers have been paying over two
hundred million dollars since tips were
introduced to the app they've even made
pickups a breeze breeze they have
color-coded
amp signs so you know what is with a
little light on their thing it's so
futuristic I can tell you right now go
to lift calm that's ly ft.com so that's
Jenna Julia you get yourself a 500 new
driver bonus and you'll have a great job
that you can create the hours for and
work between gigs and whatever it's
really awesome
also if you aren't wined delicious wine
hand-picked for you delivered to your
front door go to wink guys winc comm
they basically give you a pallet profile
quiz you answer questions of what you
think tastes good random foods doesn't
have to do with one just tastes ok they
collect the information and they store
the data about what your mouth likes ok
and then they go on pick wines based on
that
its scientific they're getting you wise
that they know you're gonna like
delicious and then they send it to your
house in a nice package box you don't
have to go the store you don't have to
look at labels anymore you just get the
wine all that hassles done with it go to
try wink that's t ry winc com2 join for
free skip any month and cancel anytime
guys plus they have a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you never pay for a bottle
that you don't like and if you use our
awesome URL go to try wink comm / Jen
and Jillian giving you $20 off your
first order and they're covering the
shipping it's a great deal thank you for
listening the real sponsor sir thank you
thank you lift and wink for letting us
do Vic sponsors hopefully we're not fart
yeah
please don't also have fake sponsors
yeah anyway back to nightmare fuel okay
yeah I want to create a volume too and I
think what I might do is I might just
create it and like quietly release it
without talking yes
Nika Bona just just sneak up sneak up
okay
I'll record it I have to get my producer
I don't know where he's been it's been
like three years since you're the
recording studio in the session yeah
sure for like months beforehand you post
pictures at like 4:00 in the morning
with youth sunglasses on the says I'm in
the studio no I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna put my phone up and self time and
picture I was gonna say I'm just
grinding and it's like in the studio
granted there was like this I'm gonna
flip the audio technica inside I'll go
right in my god just like the audio
technica works well I mean if you're
gonna be grinding then you might as well
get yourself some all-natural
skin condoms they're just you know more
natural than latex contents you did not
there's no allergies I said grinding
first it is completely not vegan
whatsoever since they're made out of
actual lambskin but if you have a latex
allergy safe sex shouldn't go into your
vagina and/or penis with the latex it's
not good for you so get yourself W don't
HTTP HTTP Thank You Jers the dark web
HD DP colon slash slash backslash it's
like this is back to us and then a force
that's like a V HDTV : v sanity link on
slash I want the condom um a wheelie
yeah at the end you did good I'm proud
of you think I'm proud of you for doing
the same ways I think you're doing good
honey you're doing great sweetie wait I
said honey sweetie honey you were
wonderful honey you were wonderful
okay you know what that is that is very
[ __ ] eh like literally no one knows
that yeah but what season was it like
this remember did you look up on YouTube
if you were ever interested which word
no there's no reason why you ever should
be but the Jabbawockeez on America's
Best Dance Crew had like an exhibition
performance after one of after not the
first season like the third or fourth if
you just look up baby walkie it's the
one where they come out they do their
little dance and then all of a sudden
they pull a little jabbawockee out of
the stereo and the little baby
jabbawockee starts [ __ ] crushing it
everyone loses their mind and then they
think they're all like cheering they're
all their feet to have the Jabbawockeez
bad news
we're exciting little mamas over there
like saying something dumb to herself in
the corner and then all of a sudden the
baby walkie pulls off the mask and it's
a little girl and and JC Shaw's I just
was like wow it's so great to have you
back blah blah blah blah JC stronsay
stuff honey you were wonderful
oh my god is so it's so funny it's
really that's it that's the story that's
all that happens do you remember the
year that was like 2011 or 12 no older
newer I think it was in 2012 cuz I
remember I was in the gym watching that
no no my melatonin protein shake after
my vigorous workout I was watching the
TV in the gym I watched that moment
exactly happens to Adi and then I drank
my melatonin protein shake by
bodybuilding calm you drink your
melatonin protein shake you get the
muscle recovery and you go right to
[ __ ] sleep I have a lot of questions
yeah ask me questions I'm the expert and
creator and CEO of melatonin literally
no one takes melatonin for a nap
I do and I figured so many people want
to sleep for like eight hours and not
wake up that's everywhere we're looking
for ways to recover from their workouts
what better way to recover in sleep no
it's daytime you can only take in the
daytime if you do that it turns into
dust and you die Jenna Julianne calms I
should tester die marble tester die or
dust or die just or die just eat the
melatonin right now and you get you get
5% on you're paying more okay you get 5%
on on your first order and I'm the
future orders it's normal price but 5%
on go to melatonin dot-com sighs Jenna
and Julian you get a military person
cheek what better way to recover from
your product what better way to recover
from your
okay try melatonin a chance it is such a
good protein chick that you were gonna
want to pay more okay it's only gonna
feel right to pay more for this thing
what's weird about that when I was in
eighth grade I bought melatonin calm as
a domain paying fees on it ever since
[Music]
you bought melatonin calm yeah did you
okay diary tell you that what where are
you going with this no no in like 2000
like 11 or 12 or something like sort of
rate when my channel started like people
were watching it like somebody bought
the domain name jenna Marbles calm yeah
you told me about this my name is jenna
Marbles blog calm and at that time I was
still like I don't remember what [ __ ]
here it is I'm like I lose my mind but
like I didn't have money like I wasn't
really making any money like I see
they're just the first job videos yeah
but like it was like $300 or something
yeah and so the person that registered
jenna Marbles calm reached out to me and
they were like hey I'm willing to sell
you this domain and I'm like I mean okay
I mean it's not cool that you registered
it anyways like I was literally just
gonna do that once I got some money
together to help get someone to help me
yeah really yeah I'll sell it to you for
$50,000 like please keep it what
[ __ ] what kind of money you think I'll
[ __ ] you means that correspondents
happen over email I think so I wonder if
he's they'll have that email be
interesting to see yeah maybe I don't
know but um it's come back well I just I
think it's just somebody that like does
that kind of thing yeah I mean it's
smart you know it's probably paid off I
guess nice comeback ya know but like
even it's been like a couple years after
that or whatever when they have like
revisited it and then they wanted to
sell it again and I'm like I don't want
to buy it like I'll give it to you for
five percent off you want to know but
like it's it's been this long without
having it like I really don't want it
it's all yours dude I'm sorry that it
didn't pay off for you 10% off $40,000
boy where did you come up with that
[ __ ] price I don't know dude but it's
like telling a 22 year old or something
thirty five forty five thousand yeah
they're like oh yeah I'll buy it from
you and you have like nothing you're
like struggling to get your dollar bills
and cash together to pay your rent and
they're like y'all so let's you for
fifty thousand dollars of like boy oh my
god that's premium right then like how
would I ever make fifty thousand dollars
from my website unless you're like you
have a store or like merch or something
but like I wasn't selling anything and
it was basically a website it was he was
doing what he probably makes a lot of
money off that he's probably reserves so
means that a lot of people with a lot of
money yes good on you for getting
melatonin calm when you were in it I did
I did it I didn't do it that was a
complete lie I never did that
I didn't buy domains up I didn't even
have money to do that right now
no melatonin dot-com it's my home page
this is a real website I don't know
probably
what about melatonin gov and melatonin
et is taken I think dan because the
education of melatonin is important it's
a new subject
oh how you doing over there we just hung
over to the
the park took the dogs to the park we
met two Aggies with the park
yep Louie and Ziggy they were really
cute really really cute features like
running all over the agility course
there's like a little agility course in
the dog park that we go to the is
probably better suited for the big dog
park yeah for the ticket doesn't look
like they have any over there like
agility so it makes me feel like
somebody that loves that dog park that
has little dogs like donut donated it to
the little dog park and literally none
of the little dogs go on any of it but
peach is so [ __ ] good at it and
everyone always looks over like you know
they all have dogs like marbles and
they're like come on but I mean it's an
extreme sport if you're looking to do
sports but you got
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you you are a natural with this egg one
thing I love your delivery because when
you're crying screaming laughing it
somehow makes the segue just so much
better this box it sure doesn't hurt
look out baby you've got competition
voices help the segues I love the voice
yeah this box is definitely premium you
know else's premium no came in jerky and
what better jerky to get then Jarrod's
came in turkey came in jerky I want to I
want to beat you I'm gonna make mine
better than you and I'm trying you and
everything away
guys if you want to go camping by a
swamp with a family of alligator and
kill the smallest one and eat it in
front of the bigger ones you're the type
of person that needs to buy Jared's came
in jerky today only in stores and also
only online the Jared's came in jerky is
this boy eat enjoy it for real compound
slash Jenna Julianne
once you go to the website your
coordinates your current geographic
coordinates will be sent to the nearest
caiman that came will run to your house
and talk to you a little bit the Cape
honor the caiman is dressed up in a
door-to-door salesman outfit he's
delivering you Gerry oh okay they're all
okay they've understood now that there's
the Jarrod's chair as a product okay are
you sure that you're eating Jared every
time you open it well the first year
that was killed in Eden was so delicious
that half of him was preserved and they
took the formula and oh my god now every
came in jerky has Jared's flavor flavor
it's only available online but also only
available in stores and also only
available at the flea market and maybe
also 7-eleven sometimes Jenna and Julian
coms last Jared
jay-ar maybe every kiss begins with
cherish he went to this boy
[Music]
I can't even respond hi Ralphie it's not
all of yours yeah how do you feel I
think you did really well I think you
made you laugh more than I've ever seen
anyone make you laugh like even when we
watched like the wheel or like the shows
where people have to survive alone and
they're like ants are so terrible like
being nicely like it's a genuine form of
torture to be like isolated from society
never talk to anyone I really genuinely
feel like for a certain amount of time
I'd be like more than fine because like
I'm I crack me up so hard you crack
yourself up the only person that cracks
you up more than you is me like how many
times do you find me around the house
just like singing myself a dumb song for
like 12 hours straight like I would be
terrible on those shows because they'd
be like holy [ __ ] shut I'm not losing
her mind perfectly fine day one like
this and is the [ __ ] save just worse
meet me is [ __ ] him well hopefully you
guys enjoyed this podcast I think this
is really that if we work I really
enjoyed it too um also if you could
please give us some feedback on the
audio is loud is it quiet is it crisper
is it not as crisp like we're really
working on this we're gonna try to
perfect this setup over the next few
episodes so that we can have an improved
product for you guys I like having
voices too I imagine we'll do them less
and less yeah we're not gonna do them
like this every episode but but they're
really fun right now cuz we've never had
them before yeah right yeah that's right
I'm gonna be gone next week but uh other
podcasts ready for you guys I know I
know I ought is 21st i encourage if
anyone is in the path of totality to
find the solar eclipse that's where i'm
going to film and no i definitely think
if anyone can watch it you should do
yeah but we'll be back next week for
another podcast hope you guys have a
great week we're on twitch all the time
so check us out there too
No all right guys see you guys later
we only do extreme things
[Music]
[Music]